uh this from president zielinski of
Ukraine he's commented about that
missile strike and he's in no doubt he
says it is a significant escalation in
the conflict and that action is needed
that from president zielinski of Ukraine
well let's uh talk to our defense and
security editor Deborah Haynes sender
Deborah president zielinski then in no
doubt as I say they're saying it is a
significant escalation and that is
precisely what NATO is trying to work
out
yes it's very important for NATO to
understand our NATO members to
understand exactly what's happened
before they can
um come out with any kind of response
because this is such a grave situation
Poland is a member of the NATO alliance
ever since the war in Ukraine was
launched by Russia there has been huge
concern about the potential for
escalation Beyond Ukraine's borders
Ukraine is not a member of the NATO
alliance and NATO allies and Russia it
has to be said have clearly tried very
hard have been trying very hard to avoid
direct confrontation between Russia and
NATO because everybody knows that that
kind of direct confrontation could lead
to a much wider War potentially the
third world war it's that serious this
is what we're talking about here and
that's why it's absolutely crucial to
understand exactly what's happened who
was responsible for these explosions was
it a deliberate strike it would seem
um perhaps not and and also then how it
happened and the NATO allies will then
be wanting to think about their response
of course there is Article 5 which is
that Collective unifying fundamental
principle of NATO an attack on one is an
attack on all and all come to the
defense of the Ally that that is under
attack but in order for Article 5 to be
implemented all allies have to agree and
so that is going to be key as well
before anyone is going to be making any
um political decision because it's a
political decision ultimately to launch
to um to make an article an article five
action
um all 30 member states will have to
agree and they'll have to agree on what
happened who was responsible and why and
so you're not going to have a rush I
don't think uh to to come out with
um an exact
um decision in in that sense
um but it is incredibly serious and
you're getting a sense of of that
seriousness from the different
statements we're getting from different
officials you've had
um NATO
um releasing a comment from an official
saying that we are looking into these
reports and closely coordinating with
our Ally Poland
um for Ukraine
um it's it's you know they you've you've
just talked about what the president was
saying about calling this an escalation
it's it's an escalation of course in the
crisis
um but the key will be whether it
whether or not it was deliberate
um and that is going to be fundamental
in NATO formulating its response and
there will be a response of some sort
um but we'll have to weigh to see what
that will look like
and Deborah as you say there well those
facts been established but what is
indisputable is that again today yet
again today Russia has been murdering
Ukrainian civilians with these missile
strikes on major population centers
right across the country which is seen
as the the Russian response to the G20
being addressed by president zielinski
it must seem quite bizarre for people
who maybe don't follow the sort of NATO
um Alliance sort of policies closely to
see a country in Europe that is clearly
very um allied with the UK with Europe
with other European NATO allies and yet
this bombardment as you say is taking
place in Ukraine and there aren't NATO
boots on the ground trying to defend the
ukrainians but it just underlines the
fact that NATO and Ukraine are separate
NATO is not directly involved in the
conflict Ukraine is not a member of the
NATO alliance and so it can't draw on
the fundamental principles of collective
defense and deterrence which is what is
enshrined by being a member of NATO and
instead though you're having individual
Nations many of them NATO member states
many of them also not
unilaterally providing support to
Ukraine with these weapons with enhanced
weapon systems the attacks today and
these blasts across the border in Poland
are already prompting uh countries such
as Latvia to speak out and talk about
increased air defenses you'll remember
at the beginning of the conflict there
was that plea from Ukraine to close the
skies to get NATO allies to come and
close protect Ukraine's airspace and at
the time countries like the UK like the
US said they they did not want to take
that step because closing the skies
would mean having British American and
other NATO Allied air defense systems
which will be surface-to-air missile
systems and uh fighter jets patrolling
the skies and shooting down potentially
Russian aircraft Russian missiles and
that is that that direct confrontation
that I was talking about before that
both sides have been trying to avoid and
so what you've seen instead of this um
this direct
intervention by countries like the UK in
terms of protecting NATO and protecting
sorry Ukraine's airspace they have been
giving Ukraine the means to protect the
airspace themselves they obviously have
their own air defense capabilities they
have their own Air Force but over the
past nearly nine months now that has
been significantly bolstered by the
weapon systems that have been coming
into Ukraine
um from across NATO Allied countries
it's not a NATO Mission it's individual
allies this is this sort of NATO
um contact group led by the United
States that have been absolutely
fundamental in helping Ukraine to
protect itself and yes we've seen today
this horrendous bombardment once more in
Ukraine but it would have been even
worse had it not been for the weapons
that Ukraine has been given to protect
itself
okay Deborah many thanks for the
assessment there our defense and
security editor Deborah Haynes uh well I
want to bring in Siobhan Robbins now uh
joins us from Berlin and Siobhan in
terms of people perhaps just joining us
let's rewind a bit and tell us more
about the circumstances what we know and
what we don't know
yes so it's been reported that a missile
or missiles Russian missile or missiles
has hit a grain store in Poland on the
Ukrainian Border in a village called
shevadov we're being told that two
people have died we know that the
pentagonist says it's looking into these
reports that the Polish prime minister
has called an emergency meeting saying
this is a crisis situation he's talking
to his defense officials now to find out
what's going on we know a similar
situation is happening in Hungary as
well they're having an emergency meeting
too and we're getting reaction from
various countries across Europe and also
in the US and I think what's important
to know which everyone has been saying
tonight is there's very very cautious
language whether it's coming out of NATO
or the us or Europe around what has
happened and that shows you just how
tense this situation is I'm going to
give you a flavor of some of the limes
that have been coming out of various
places so that you can really really get
up to speed with what's going on so
first of all we've had NATO saying we're
looking into these reports and closely
coordinating with our Ally Poland then
we've had president zielinski of Ukraine
saying we've warned that Russia's
actions are not limited to Ukraine
Reuters news agency reporting that the
Russian defense Ministry denies that
these are Russian missiles liberally
striking Poland it says that it's a
deliberate provocation to escalate the
situation and then we've had Estonia
coming out saying this is most alarming
the Czech Republic saying if Poland
confirms the missiles also hit its
territory this will be a further
escalation by Russia and really that's
the point now that everyone is looking
at was this a deliberate attack on
Poland which we know has been extremely
strong in its stance against Russia ever
since this war in Ukraine broke out or
was this an accident that's what the
conversations will be going on behind
the scenes right now what's going to
happen because we've said it time and
time again and over the last hour or so
the big problem here is that Poland is a
NATO member and that is an issue because
if this is a deliberate attack then
there'll be conversations around whether
other NATO members should react to
protect this member it wouldn't happen
immediately as you've heard from Deborah
Haynes and they'll obviously be
discussions about you know was this an
accident was this something that the
Russians can deny to defuse the
situation but they will be the key
questions now being looked at around the
world
okay Siobhan thank you very much Siobhan
Robin's there in Berlin and uh you'll
have heard Siobhan telling us there that
the Russian defense Ministry denying any
involvement in the incident at all
saying it's a deliberate provocation so
let's get more now on the view from
Moscow with uh correspondent there Diana
Magna and uh Diana I suppose pretty much
expected that this would be the Russian
position presumably then they're saying
it's a so-called false flag operation
well they're just saying that it doesn't
have anything to do with them and that
there were no strikes from Russian
missile systems along the Ukrainian
Polish border today and that the photos
that are appearing on polish media of
the weapons debris have nothing to do
with Russian weapons and they're calling
it a deliberate provocation in order to
escalate the situation
um so I mean I think there are two
possible theories one is was this a
mistake the other is is it a way of
testing NATO's resolve at a time when
the G20 is taking place President Putin
is obviously not there it could also be
that for example this was one of those
missiles that was one of many today
striking key Ukrainian energy
infrastructure especially which was
taken down by Ukrainian air defense and
we have debris hitting in Poland and we
know that two people were killed so
there are a number of possible
eventualities
and as we were hearing from lordanes as
we were hearing from Deborah Haynes
there I think that it will take a lot of
cool Minds to make sure that there is no
dramatic escalation
um but uh you know knowing Russia's
track record it is quite possible that
they would try and test the waters with
a strike which they can plausibly deny
but at the same time if this was just
one of the many missiles that hit
Ukraine or were targeted at Ukraine
today and was taken down by Ukrainian
air defense and it landed the other side
of the Border then that too is a very
real possibility so I I think we're in a
dangerous situation one where of course
you have all the leaders of Eastern
Europe and NATO uh wondering what to do
next and one where I imagine if the
ministry of defenses latest post is to
go by Russia will deny over and over
again
um the question is if we discount the
idea that this was an accident what is
Vladimir Putin trying to achieve
um does he really want to escalate this
in a way that involves NATO of course in
his own country his people are being
told continually that this is
essentially an effectively a war against
nato in any case and that NATO is
supplying the weapons to Ukraine NATO is
essentially the master of Ukraine that
this is a war for Russia's defense
against NATO and I have no doubt that
President Putin feels pretty aggrieved
that he's not sitting as a trusted
member of the G20 or in fact in the G20
at all and wants to make Mark the moment
especially after president zielinski's
address calling it the g19
ETC
but whether he chooses whether he is
choosing to make a deliberate strike on
a NATO member State knowing the the
consequences knowing the
responsibilities for all NATO members
under Article 5 is a completely
different story and I think that a cool
heads should Prevail we need to sit
tight and try and work out what went on
Diana many thanks Diana magnet in Moscow
there and let's just share with you a
photograph just in of the aftermath of
that strike on the Polish Village for
shevidov on the border with Ukraine well
you can see here the the notable plume
of smoke there that's what we've got so
far those reports that are Russian
missile has crossed the border between
Ukraine and Poland and hit that Village